so we recently had a really fun day here
at periodic videos when a good friend of
our project Michael Stevens from the
channel Vsauce paid a visit now Michael
was making his own video and I'm sure
you've probably already seen that but he
allowed us to film a little bit behind
the scenes and maybe show you a few
outtakes a few things you normally
wouldn't get to see first of all here we
are in the lab with Neil of course and
we're playing with gold I've got I
forgot what they called glove hands
gloves just fit me like gloves like a
glove this is a really cool background -
this will look really silly but I think
I'm gonna pop into the frame like I do
gold of course is famously unreactive
which is why it's such a great way to
store your wealth if you have a bunch of
gold laying around the likelihood that
it will dissolve or rust or evaporate is
very evaporate whoever is like oh I just
can't find anything that won't evaporate
in particular one discovered in the
1300s with the fancy name aqua Riga it's
made out of hydrochloric acid and nitric
acid and we're about to make some right
now thanks to Neil from periodic videos
Wow fumes that came off the nitric acid
what what was that what gasps of course
we're using this field cupboard because
the fumes that come off the nitric acid
are quite dangerous let's put some gold
in aqua regia and for the gold we're
just gonna use this ancient priceless
Egyptian relic let's go ahead and try
this out I can I do it here we go gold
in aqua regia oh that poor guy and as
the gold dissolves what we wind up with
in the evaporating dish is Morro auric
acid I thought it was way more violent
than it was going to be I thought it
would sit there and we would say well
okay we leave come back and not know if
someone had just taken it but no that
thing bubbled and
struggled for its life and flopped
around like a like a dying fish it was
almost kind of sad
next we turned our attention to sulphur
and of course one of our favorite
reactions here at periodic videos the
barking dog' which means it's gonna bark
that'll be what I say let's just go I
mean of course a fun thing to do with
sulphur is to make it bark like a dog
here's what we're gonna do obviously I'm
nervous but I'm trying to show my
bravery on camera the camera adds 15
pounds and it adds a bunch of bravery if
I was doing this alone I'd probably have
Brady do it how can you tell when it's
there's enough it looks like heat
ripples you know
I'm just nervous about the noise you
know I was the kind of kid who loved
fireworks but not the kind that went up
and and went just made a noise of course
I'm liking them more as I as I mature
I'm also liking deep bass in my music I
think it's related
[Applause]
Wow and look at all the sulfur on the
sides of the tube mmm I can smell it
reminds me of my father what my father's
a sulphur engineer he he I mean my
goodness he's a salt the sulfur King
what do you think well at first I was
like nothing's happening this is so easy
and then it got really loud and loud
like bass drum in a marching band next
to you loud not
ouch more like whoa I'm glad I didn't
have to go to the bathroom look at that
yeah it's great next cab off the rank
was the element vanadium and a reaction
I hadn't actually seen before up close
involving color changes and oxidation
states here's what we got up to huh and
then you could hand me the jar and I'll
say we're just kidding this is an
aqueous solution of vanadium metal okay
in this jar is zinc dissolved in mercury
it's metal it's it's heavier than you
would think which is a really cool
feeling and when we mix vanadium in with
the mercury and the zinc the mercury
helps the zinc give electrons to the
vanadium and as it gains more and more
electrons it changes color that's the
wrong stopper all right so I'm gonna
give it one shake mmm another shake Wow
this is a different blue right mm-hmm
some pretty forest green I love shaking
this it's crazy it's like throwing me
off balance it's so heavy look at that
Thank You electrons yeah I wasn't sure I
think I put in the right amount and
lastly the metal cerium which we ordered
in specially from our friends at
sigma-aldrich and Michael put into a
Bunsen burner you see the word cerium
this is powdered cerium a metal that
when exposed to a flame produces a very
beautiful sparkle I think we should take
a look
tada science Thank You electrons
there's always that's great that's great
now with all the elements and all the
reactions we could have done you're
probably wondering why did we choose
these ones and a lot of you have
probably already figured out if you take
the symbols of all these elements au for
gold s for sulfur V for vanadium and
seee for cerium and you do a bit of
rearranging you get Vsauce and that's
the name of Michael's channel so we
thought he'd like that and then when we
finished I took Michael along to the
professor's lab now the professor was
out the two have met before but the
professor wasn't in Nottingham that day
but he had left a gift that he wanted
passed on especially the famous ties can
I touch them you can touch the tars
maybe some of his style will rub off on
me well we've got one better cuz Martin
was really sorry he couldn't be here but
he asked that I give you one of one of
his collection as well no way it's from
you from the professor that's one of his
that's one of his periodic table ties he
knows you're a casual dresser but maybe
one day you'll find an excuse to wear
one well this is this is not just nice
this is an honor so thank you very much
professor Polyakov I I don't know if I
should frame it or just wear it every
day and thanks to Marco for paying a
visit it was really good to have him and
show him around the lab we'll be back
again soon with more of our usual videos
[Music]
[Applause]
you
[Music]